Hãy gần hôm tí tình như mê nè hai người ta tháng 3 tuyên bố đến tính hành chính xí quân sự đồng tiến với xưa ảo,
sự dùng loa tên lộ đàn đạo nhóm và cơm mục tiêu quân sự tại tuyên mê nè.
Nói vân ngôn quân sự, giai a sòi khẩn định, chứ dựng đám đau đồng mục tiêu đề ra,
đồng thời nhấn mạnh hành động này nhằm thị hệ sự đoàn kết với y ra và tất cả lực lượng đồng mình trong vực.
Chúng khi đó, lực lượng phòng base rào y đẹp, sát nhận đá phát hiện tình lộ phòng từ giây mê,
và thế quà thiện thống phòng không để đánh chạp, chuyến thông xin rời trời mê thật của đảm đá bị vô hiệu hã và không gây ra thương văn.
Kháng tình loa tên lộs và tán tình trong khu vực. Đồng thái này của hồ Thí dễn xa,
sau khi lực lượng này cạnh báo, sẽ tâm thiệt quân sự nếu xung đột tiếp tục lao thang.
Thánh thẳng giữa các bên giá tăng kể tự ki nghĩ về xưa ảo phát động chế sự quân sự nhà biê răng tự của tháng 2.
Sau đó, đánh yên trọng lòng sang libang, làm ra tăng quý câu khủng hoàn nhấn đạo tới khu vực.
Giờ quan sân nhận định, về khu thí tháng chiến của thị là mở giống phản ví xung đột,
ra thẳng giữ gió đối với anh đi khu vực và các tuyến vận tại chính lộ.